- Jonathan's life goal was to see
how many different ways
he could piss me off.
- No, no, no, no, that's not true at all.
(blues rock instrumental music)
- People used to think we
were twins because, no.
Get outta here.
- Jennifer had all these
idiosyncratic like,
things that would just annoy her.
- And Jonathan would go
out of his way to do them.
- He thinks he's always
supposed to get his way.
- I'm just right.
- He used to also do this
hand clapping thing that
was really obnoxious.
(hollow clapping)
(guitar chord sustained)
- I was at school.
Instead of going to class,
two of my friends were like,
let's go to Morongo, this Indian casino.
Me and my friend called the
school as each other's dads
and say that we weren't gonna be in today.
So we go, I go with
eight bucks in my pocket
and just dreams, and I come back.
I make $88 dollars, 11 times.
I earned it, which is awesome.
- So my mom texts me and asked
if my brother was in school,
and my friends were like,
"Oh, he went to Morongo".
And I was like, "No Mom,
he went to the casino,
where you can't play because he's not 18".
- And all of a sudden your
Mom calls and you're like,
"It's cool guys, I got this."
And I'm like thinking,
telling my mom that,
"Oh yeah, I'm at, I'm at school right now"
when she already knows
from this one right here,
who I thought might bail me out.
Devastation.
She did me wrong, and I
wasn't gonna let it go by.
It was a lot of me, giving
Sarah the silent treatment.
- This was like our longest fight.
At first, I'm like, I don't care,
like whatever, but he would
try to rub it in my face.
Finally, my mom knew that
I was the better child,
that I am the good girl
that God has given them,
and he is you know, what he is.
- Early high school, I
was sitting on my bed,
I had our dog Cindy,
she was you know, cute little dog,
and my sister barges into my room,
and she's like, "I want the dog!",
like in my room.
- (laughs) No.
- And I'm like, "No, it's
my turn to have the dog,
I'm studying hard", I grabbed the dog,
my sister like goes and punched me,
I put up my left hand,
just nails my pinky,
and I knew right away it was broken.
- It was really light.
- No, it was pretty...
- It was light.
- She packs a punch.
- He acted like it was World War Three,
that life was ending,
the house is on fire.
He calls my dad, and he
goes to the emergency room.
The next day, I went to a party.
- So I go into my sister's room,
she had all these dressers
and sets of drawers and stuff,
so I like, topple them.
- Break it, smash it.
- No, I didn't break them.
I emptied the contents
like all over her room.
- And I came back and all my
stuff was lying on the floor,
and one of the things he put
into the room was a vacuum.
Full out of anger, I grabbed the vacuum
and I went to attack my brother with it.
False swing? The shoulder?
- She doesn't really have a good swing so.
- So it didn't work out.
- I mean, it's no worse
than the time she uhh...
(laughing)
- Shut the (bleep) up.
I'll kill you.
(blue rock instrumental)
- I've grown to be a person
who doesn't hold grudges,
very like, I don't
really hold them anymore.
- Anymore.
- Yeah, I used to.
- Key word, anymore.
- Oh, we still get in fights.
- No, we don't get in any fights.
(laughing)
- I think it's normal for
brothers and sisters to fight
when you're growing up
because you gotta see
the good and the bad in each
other to really know somebody.
If you don't fight,
you're lying to yourself.
- For the most part we're cool.
- Right, high five.
(smack)
- We're a team.
- We should call my
parents and tell them this.
They'll be shocked.
(laughing)
(blues rock instrumental music)
- [Deyo] Are there things today
that we still fight about?
- [Sarah] He owes me money.
(laughing)
- Yeah I do, she's pimping me.
- Where my money at?
(whoosh and squeaking)